hello thanks for joining us today my
name is Jonathan Glasgow I'm a project
scientist of the gene lab project at
NASA Ames Research Center and I'm very
happy to tell you about some exciting
work we're doing the title of my talk is
using the nasa gene lab data system to
study the metagenomes of spaceships and
their occupants this is actually gonna
be a three-part talk I'll introduce some
of the broad concepts that we'll be
discussing and then I'll hand off to two
of my colleagues Peng and Daniella to
tell you more about some of the
up-to-date science that's happening
okay so there's renewed interest in
pushing farther out into space and we're
interested in living and working beyond
low-earth orbit
this means destinations such as the moon
and eventually hopefully Mars but
traveling and this is nicely depicted in
these artistic posters and so we can all
look forward to vacations on the moon or
the Mars and Gateway is actually going
to be a small space station that will be
used in transits not to the moon but
during travel to these destinations and
and during stays at these destinations
in deep space there's a series of
challenges that we'll have to overcome
related to human health and these are
summarized here as five hazards hazard
one shown in pink is exposure to space
radiation there's a variety of different
radiation particles that astronauts and
other spacefaring humans would be
exposed to during transit and at
destinations and it's a potential risk
to their health hazard to is isolation
so the psychological effects of being in
space isolated from the broader human
population family is an important
consideration hazard three and yellow is
the distance from Earth so as we move
move further away it becomes harder and
harder to evacuate astronauts down to
earth where they could receive expert
medical care
hazard for in maroon and is exposure to
different gravity fields this includes
high gravity fields during launch or
re-entry as well as low gravity fields
when on orbit and finally hazard 3 our
excuse me 5 which is most relevant to
this talk is exposure to hostile or
closed environments and part of the
concern with this hazard is in fact
exposure to a microbiome of a spacecraft
which is relatively uncharacterized so
the broad question that were interested
in answering is what is the microbiome
of a generic spacecraft or a specific
spacecraft such as the International
Space Station and what types of risks
does that microbiome composition pose to
astronauts moving forward and so this
risk has actually been codified by NASA
this is a a slide developed by NASA to
really define this risk can the risk is
host microorganism interactions no
there's a series of knowledge gaps that
have been identified and NASA is now in
the process of doing experiments and
evaluating how what these the severity
these risks and how these risks this
risk could be mitigated so along these
lines in 2011 the National Research
Council recommended to NASA and
specifically the NASA life and physical
sciences research and applications
program that a microbial Observatory be
set up on the ISS and the broad concept
here is that NASA should systematically
assess the microbial population on the
International Space Station including
any dynamics as astronauts come and go
and begin to assess what that what that
microbiome looks like and what what
risks are associated with this
and so NASA has made some progress on
addressing these recommendations for
example a P I led effort called
microbial tracking one involved taking
systematic samples of the International
Space Station a variety of different
surfaces and determining which microbes
were there using a variety of different
assays including isolating microbes but
also performing a shotgun meta genomics
and on the right side here you'll see a
series of population but publications
that have come out of this effort and
you can of course go and and read these
publications to understand what is being
seen on the international space station
but what I'd like to point out is a
different way that you can begin to to
look at this data and to actually
analyze this data on on your own and
come up with your own conclusions and
this is something that we're really
eager to have the community of
scientists at large do because the
opportunity for this type of
experimentation is relatively rare and
it's very there's very limited
opportunity to bring experimental
payloads up and down into orbit and so
we really want the broad community to
engage with this data and to reuse it as
much as possible so how can how can you
do that so nASA has developed a data
system called NASA gene lab and you can
get to this by going to gene lab
nasa.gov I'll have the link at the end
of this talk and at its core what this
data system allows any-any
scientists to do is to download data
from a variety of space biology
experiments and to analyze it using your
own pipelines to come up with your own
conclusions develop new hypotheses so in
gene lab there's a variety of different
studies there's as of September 3rd 2019
there were 211 studies and these are
broadly
broken into either space flight studies
or ground-based analogs studies so a
ground-based analogs studies would be
controlled exposure to radiation or an
unloading experiment or the effects of
gravity can be minimized such as through
a high limb unloading experiment in a
mouse gene lab includes data from a
variety of organisms including animals
plants and but also microbes most of the
gene lab data system consists of
transcription profiling and most of that
is micro right within gene lab there are
a number of very interesting
microbiology datasets
so these datasets span all all three
kingdoms from bacteria archaea and
eukaryotes and they also include data
for some very interesting payloads on
the on the right I'm showing pictures of
the expose our payload in which microbes
were exposed to true space these and the
the question is what what would survive
when exposed to the vacuum of space but
on top of that and this is through the
main focus of what we're talking about
are actually what we call in a wild
space samples so this includes profiling
of the microbiome of the International
Space Station so in particular the
Mercurial tracking one data is within
gene lab and so the microbiome profiling
data sets and gene lab are all
summarized here there are on this slide
I'm quite a few but in red I've actually
highlighted one that you will hear about
after my talk this is G LDS 2:12
reproducible changes and the gut
microbiome reveal shift in microbial and
host metabolism during spaceflight and
gyeongjong will be speaking about this
this is his effort to understand
actually what's happening to the
microbiome of mice which are flown on
the International Space Station okay but
how can you get this data and I very
much encourage you to get this data and
to analyze it and this slide shows you
how to do this so you go to gene lab at
nasa.gov on the left side I'm showing a
search form
Kerbel observatory that brings up a
number of data sets you simply click on
these data sets so you can follow that
that bottom red rectangle up to the top
and you'll see that that brings you to
that data set
you could then click on the samples tab
and that tells you about all of the
samples that are associated with that
data set you can then look through the
metadata associated with those samples
download the raw data and begin to do
your own analyses you can even imagine
downloading a series of these and do it
starting to do a meta analysis we very
much encourage you to do this this is
very valuable data and we want to get as
much discovery out of it as possible so
to summarize again how how can you get
involved in analyzing this this very
exciting data go to Jean lab Bob
nasa.gov download and begin analyzing
anybody can do that and for those who
are with technical skills and have a
keen interest on in collaborating with
like-minded scientists like the like
bangin and Daniela who you'll hear from
next and myself we actually have
something called analysis working groups
these are open groups these are
individuals with the technical skills
necessary to analyze this data we bring
these people together to collaborate on
analyses and joint publications and if
you want to get involved in those groups
you can go to Gina at nasa.gov /a WGS
words last join and there's just a short
application and we'd be happy happy to
have you okay so thank you for listening
again please go to gene lab and and look
around and I'm very happy to hand things
off to pan Jong who's gonna tell you
about some very exciting results he has
gotten regarding changes in the
microbiome of mice that have been flown
on the International Space Station thank
you thanks John so in the next 15
minutes or so I'm gonna to tell you a
little bit about our recent work
regarding the gut microbiome during
spaceflight and this work is also a good
example of how the research team and
afterwards NASA Ching lab in the pursuit
of some really interesting biological
questions so the biological question
we're really interested in is the gut
microbiome how does it change during
spaceflight and what those changes mean
with regard to mammalian physiological
functions the study of gut microbiome is
really one of the hottest areas right
now in biomedical research and numerous
studies have shown that the gut
microbiome interacts with many aspects
of mammalian physiological functions and
the gut microbiome is also very
sensitive to external stimulus and
changes promptly once the environment
environment changes so if you think
about the spaceflight astronauts
actually are challenged by some really
unique environmental factors such as
micro gravity and radiation losing
environmental factors are expected to
change the gut microbiome composition
and this would have really important
implications for pronounced health
especially during long-term spaceflight
so previously our groups is also a part
of the NASA twin study this is a very
large multi institution multi group
study to look at multi-omics of twing
astronaut scott kelly during his
one-year mission onboard the
International Space Station so our group
are focused on the gut microbiome and
movies we saw in in the twin study is
that space fly actually induces or
associated it with some unique changes
in the gut microbiome that we didn't see
in in in in the ground swing it Mark
Kelly is twin brother
that stayed on the ground for the entire
period at the time
so those changes include first of all
there's a increase in the microbial are
for diversity this is a measure for the
micro evenness and and richness this is
actually also a a kind of surprising
finding for us because the the
International Space Station is thought
to be a relatively closed environment
and the closely environments are
oftentimes associated with a decrease in
alpha diversity but during spaceflight
we actually saw an increase in a in the
microbial diversity and secondly we we
saw a significant change in the
microbial community structure this is
true for both the tectonic compose
composition as well as the microbial
gene content and thirdly when we look at
the the relative abundance of two of the
most abundant bacterial phyla in in a
mammalian gut the firm the firmicutes
and Bacteroides we saw a significant
increase in the Firmicutes two
factorials ratio this is giving you a
like like a really high level in index
of large changes in the gut microbiome
so with those findings we we kind of
have a first glance of what kind of
microbiome changes the there would be
during spaceflight however there are a
lot of important questions remain to be
answered the first of all well we wanted
to to to know whether those changes are
robust or reproducible especially given
that the twin study is essentially a n
equals to 1 study and secondly we want
to know what kind of
environmental factors that actually
contributed to the changes of gut
microbiome we see there in spaceflight
and thirdly we want to know whether our
true what they extend those microbiome
changes actually interacted with the
host and what kind of house implication
we would draw from from the changes in
the microbiome to also those studies we
really need a well-designed animal study
so or study of the we're trying to study
the the mice so the first mouse study of
the gut microbiome during space star fly
we did is actually taking advantage of
some existing samples from the Rudin
research one mission this is actually
the first Rudin research mission that
flew that has utilized the the
International Space Station the the
purpose of this mission is actually to
validate the hardwired and operation
procedures for routine research missions
but the samples are actually available
so we can request them through the nasa
our spaceman sharing program and the r-1
mission involves four groups of animals
you have the flight animals they spend a
total of 37 days in space and also you
have three groups of control animals on
the ground
these include what we call the ground
control these animals stage in not only
the same mouse habitat as you seen ISS
but also those habitats are were placed
into a chamber called the ISS a
environmental simulator what this does
is actually collects the data in
environmental data in
including the temperature humidity and
co2 levels onboard the ISS and simulates
the exact the condition in this ISS
environmental simulator the the ground
control animals stayed in the simulator
for a total of six seven thirty seven
days to other control groups includes
the vivarium control in which the
animals are were housed - just under
standard uh Bavarian conditions and
lastly you have the basel group which
kind of give you a sense of what the
baseline look like as those animals were
euthanized just one day after the the
launch of the flight groups so when we
got those fecal samples from the those
animals we process the samples and
performed 1660s ribosome are and
sequencing and all those data are now
available through king lab so what we
see in the r-1 microbiome is that first
of all we see an increase in alpha
diversity and you can see from this
figure here the flight animals actually
shows the highest level of the are for
diversity and at the same time you you
see the are for diverse be in the flight
and ground animals are higher than the
bavarian and basil groups so that
indicates that flight spaceflight is
self as a in fact to increase that for
diversity at the same time the diocese
housing environment including the the
habitats use the the co2 levels the
temperature and humidity also appear to
to increase the microbial alpha
diversity during spaceflight and
secondly we look at the beta diversity
this is a description of the community
structure of the gut microbiome so on
this graph each circle
sample and they are colored according to
the groups of the the animals and you
can see here essentially the basal and
and bavarian samples are
indistinguishable from each other
but they are very different from the
flight and ground samples so that again
tells us that the the ISS housing
environment had a major impact on the
market microbiome composition at the
same time you will see a nice separation
between the flight and ground animals
here indicating that indicate in
addition to the the housing conditions
space flight itself also has a effect
modulating the gut microbiome and
thirdly when we look at the the
firmicutes to Bacteroides ratio we see a
increase in the firm accusing and to
backwards ratio in flight animals as
well so just to summarize if you were if
you recall what we saw in the twin study
we saw elevated R for diversity we saw a
change in the community structure and we
saw a elevator the firmicutes tube
actually this ratio all those major
findings in the twin studies are
actually consistent with what we saw
here in mice
during the r1 mission now those results
are encouraging
but at the same time we're wondering if
we could have some way to to look at
data in a more systematic way or if we
can come up with a way to perform a
formal statistical testing to ask
whether the microbiome changes during
space flight reproducible so to do that
we actually develop the method that we
call star maps this method uses the the
principal component and
and the basic idea of this analysis is
that if you have my data set
measuring say microbe our microbes a and
B and those microbes are showing a
differential abundance because of some
some condition and you will be able to
see a separation of the two groups when
you plot the data in a microbial species
axis and if you have a second data set
that produced by the same condition you
would expect some similar changes for
from micros a and B even though in this
case the the actual amount of the actual
abundance of of microbes a and B may be
different from what you see in dataset
one but in an the the the the
differential abundance patterns should
be quite similar so in this case when
you perform a dimension reduction
techniques such as principal component
analysis the the principal components
that captures the difference group
differences in data set one should also
capture this difference in in data set 2
so essentially star maps is a way to
project a second data set onto the same
principle component space of the first
dataset and to ask the question what are
the groups segregations you see in those
two data sets or comparable to each
other so using this method we compared
the r1 data to publicly available data
set investigating microbiome changes
during a space flight mission this is
actually the last space shuttle mission
which involved actual
some my study that spent about 14 days
on there I'm bored so this so this study
using using this data said we can
actually project the samples from the
sts-135 samples onto the same principal
component space of r1 and as you see
here once we do that you see a similar
segregation between the ground and
flight animals in the SS sts-135 mission
in a very similar fashion as you will
see in the in our one mission and this
tells us that indeed the spaceflight
associated the changes in the gut
microbiome is reproducible but between
the previous sts-135 mission and the r1
mission so next we investigated whether
the space radiation also has a effect
yeah in in the gut microbiome and
whether those my space radiation induced
the effect are comparable to the r1
mission the reason we are interested in
this radiation
is that when you think about the the
major differences between the grunt
animals and flight animals those
differences include whether they're in
exposed to microgravity and whether they
are exposed to space radiation so
previously people have been studying the
effect of space like radiation on earth
so there are actually two of such
datasets available studying different
kind of
radiation exposure both result when some
aspects of the radiation exposure you
would expect in space we downloaded
those data and we are not reanalyzed
them so basically we can we can see
those space space type radiation produce
a effect in the gut microbiome but when
we projected those samples onto the
principal component space of our r1
those the segregation of those those
samples are just not similar to what we
see between the flight and ground groups
in in in r1 so this results indicates
that even though the space type
radiation can produce a effect in the
gut microbiome those changes in the
microbiome are just not similar as what
we saw during spaceflight in r1 one
thing I should point out is that the
type radiation actually represents more
of a deep space voyage conditions while
the r1 mission is onboard the
International Space Station which
operates on the low Earth orbit where
you the the radiation effect is not at
its full strengths you used to have some
shielding effect from the Earth's
magnetic field so that you don't you
don't have the maximum exposure of
radiation as you would in in deep deep
space voyages so future studies are
still needed to look for what would be
the effect of deep space travels whether
the the microbiome changes under those
conditions can be seen as a as a mixture
of both what we see in r1 as well as
what we see in those spec
Space Flight radiation studies on earth
nevertheless given those results right
now we are actually leaning more towards
other factors especially microgravity
which may have a major impact or have
contributes the most to the observed
microbiome changes during spaceflight
next we also investigated some like like
what's the the functional implication of
the microbiome changes even though the
16s data we generated from our one
mission does not directly give us the
microbial gene content we actually can
use a bioinformatics tool called pie
crust to predict the microbial gene
content based on the taxonomical
composition and we can perform a
differential balance analysis based on
those inferred microbial gene abundance
so on the right here the he map actually
shows the differential abundance pattern
of the microbial pathway genes and the
tech home message here is the there are
many genes or microbial pathways show a
differential gene abundance during
spaceflight that are different between
the flight and the ground animals and
roughly they can be clustered into three
groups based on their their differential
balance pattern in general all those
pathways are actually centered on the on
the to to to to a theme of energy
metabolism so in general what we see
here is we saw a increase of of gene
abundance
involved in fermentation as a way of
energy production while at the same time
there's a decrease in the gene abundance
involved of using other materials such
as aiming as a source of energy or to
use respiration as a source as a way to
produce energy
so this data suggests that there are the
changes in the gut microbiome
composition is linked to a change in
them in the microbial capability of
energy metabolism next we want to
investigate whether there's a way for us
infer functional interaction between the
gut microbiome and the host during
spaceflight and this is where data on
gene-lab become really helpful because
there are actually data already on jane
black that profile gene expression in
the liver in the same set of that one
so we performed a correlation analysis
between the the gene expression data in
the liver and the the gut microbiome
abundance data we generated in the same
animals this time we're focusing on the
inferred abundance of microbial pathways
that are showing difference between the
flight and the ground animals and we can
the on the top panel here show a show we
show the number of host liver genes
whose expression are correlated with the
microbial pathway abundance for each of
the microbiota
pathways and we also control the fact
that the correlation are performed in
animals of different groups we actually
remove the
the group you factus so that's the coral
correlation are more likely true in for
a interaction between the host liver
gene expression this is a micro vine
pathway gene path functional pathway
abundance so after this this correction
one pathway really stand out the
precreasing degradation pathway as
showing them a second role on the on the
top panel here after correction for the
groupie effect there are still a large
number of genes that are significantly
correlated with the purchasing
degradation pathway those are as showing
in the dark shade blue and red here
those those host the genes are actually
involved in you in essentially every
step along the protein in the table
pathway there are involved in protein
synthesis folding and degradation well
this is a really interesting observation
because your tracing is a small molecule
that it's essential for mammalian cell
function but at the same time if you
have too much of you tracing you would
end up with a huge suppression of
protein synthesis so what we see here
during spaceflight is that there's a
decrease of pew tracing degradation
pathway in the gut microbiome during
spaceflight that could lead to a
decreased capacity of gut microbes to
break down to tracing leaving a surplus
of tracing and this increase of purse
raising may actually may contribute to a
decrease the protein metabolism in the
host and now will they explain the the
observation that the the protein
synthesis pathway genes in the host
liver i also are also decreased in its
expression during spaceflight and again
low
those observations really need future
studies to value to verify and and to to
look for more deeper analysis to confirm
those findings but at this point those
findings actually gave us a really
interesting hypothesis for ongoing
studies to pursue so as a conclusion
from the our one study which we've seen
a increased alpha diversity we see a
change in the committed structure of the
gut microbiome and those changes are
actually reproduce fall compared to
previous studies and interestingly the
the face flag associated gut microbiome
changes are not the same as radiation
induced changes indicating nudge factors
other than radiation during spaceflight
presumably microgravity may have
contribute the most to the changes in
the gut microbiome during spaceflight
and lastly we also see those changes in
both the host and and the microbiome
suggesting a shift of the my metabolic
state there which a is really a focus
area for our ongoing study so with those
findings were very excited for what
we've been doing now which is a
dedicated Rubin research mission for
microbiome study especially with a focus
on how the microbiome would interact was
the host physiology during spaceflight
this this study involves two different
Mouse friends those inbred mouse strains
are essentially like the
twins within each strand they're
genetically identical but between the
strands they are very different so that
by by including two different Mouse
impressed friends but essentially be
able to perform a mouse version of the
the twins that we will be able to look
at changes within individuals of the the
same genetic makeup and also to compare
against a mouse with very different
genetic makeup and that would give us a
sense how the host genome would impact
the the micro microbiome changes during
during spaceflight and at the same time
we will be able to record video
recordings to analyze their sleep-wake
behavior what I haven't had a time to
tell you about is that sleep wake or
sleep problems is really a persisting
challenge for astronauts during space
flight we wanted to see whether those
space spaceflight associated the with
associated the microbiome changes has
anything to do with the sleep changes we
see during spaceflight whether there's
some interaction there as well and also
the the r7 is actually a record long
during research missions the animals
will stay in space for 25 days and as
long as and another group was to stay as
long as for 75 days so and lastly
another thing we're really excited about
is that we're actually now working more
closely with NASA king lab actually we
will perform the rst [ __ ] Express says
with with with gene lab so that all the
stem poles will
we'll be processed in the same standard
way that will allow even a better cross
study comparison so with that I would
like to thank everybody involved in
those those studies both the twin study
and r1 and our seven studies especially
the P is of those studies Frederick
muscle Berger the Turner and Stefan
groom and thank you for your attention
and I'll turn it over to vanilla hello
my name is daniela based on and it's an
honor for me to talk today on the roads
on behalf of Jean laughs and I would
like to explain a little bit our
experiments our projects with NASA and
in general microbiomes
so we are having currently a number of
collaboration namespace health for
example JPL in Los Angeles where we
working mostly with the NASA Mars rover
and also the Department of Planning
winter protection and then of course we
working together to take study well one
of the most one of the main altars of
the Train study of Martin Scott Kelly
and Scott have been one year space on
the ice s space station and Mark is
identical twin happening on earth and
it's an absolutely unique opportunity to
study both and see a house how actually
human health is affected by their harsh
conditions in space and several other
projects which I explained the look like
all these projects and all these data
and experiments have to be bundled it
have been organized and gene-lab have
been moment gene lab is so much more
than that that I was worried but were a
little bit later
and what I would like to explain is how
we can see the word is I'm working
mainly with microorganism microorganism
n' are fundamentally important for human
health actually micro organism and
follow-up us for all our development
human development so we have for example
the toddler who is used to stuff things
whenever finding everybody knows that na
ma and interacting with the microbial
world and also like in every stage you
know with a little proper progress with
every age we have a different microbiome
variant acting this and so if we want to
understand it's actually a microorganism
and microbiome and modern environments
we have to study more environments and
what are actually modern environments
and today very simple a smartphone is
also modern environment today we taking
our smartphone one of our most personal
attempt everywhere to ever eat like we
take it to dinner
Simonne us take it to the restroom the
microphone microbiome and our smartphone
is representing who we are and what we
are so we studied to understand what
environments the microcosm biomes on
these smartphones and we were able
actually to see we are able to see
different microorganisms you came to
associations but also traces of human
DNA which were enough to actually be
dipped ancestry where this person's come
from but also context this person have
at home what this person ate that day
and of course societally more related
irrelevant information like antibiotic
resistance bacteria motors is material
on these smartphones and we are
currently we analyzed money 2000
smartphones and the whole gene
sequencing
and nother one now we have this personal
matter we have to think in one global
context so we already have these
smartphones which are collected during
my conferences a very embroil community
but let's get somewhere a lot of
diversity diverse culture diets
different people different ancestry and
one of the densest areas where we can
study in microcosm in a very variant of
Newman's if heard the subways on the new
subway a transport every day 5.6 million
people and all from different urging
different diets and different habits and
studying this mechanism would give us a
great estimate how a particular area
would look like and how actually
bacteria travel in mass transit systems
and there's always bounded meters up in
2013 where we have currently more than
100 cities in 25 countries or mean
actually analyzing and sequencing
samples from mass transit systems like
subway station and it is just amazing
what we're learning all of this means
for example we can see a lot of
undiscovered diversity we can we can
actually money tor transmission routes
of intruder assistance with resistance
bacteria and they are prevalent but in
the dominant but it can get a pretty
much estimate how things are actually
moving and also we can see there is a
clear correlation between cities and
communities and energy profiles which
have been expected but not proven and we
currently Anna publishing process so
please say please look it up it will be
on my soon and this is all very
interesting but
how the residence like actually worked
beside of subways because we already
found these unclassified microorganism
and we can even drink so how extreme
sites actually the microbiome what would
look like so for example and a corner
you seen your gasket which is burning
since 1978 and gene-lab member and
friend colleague Jeff and weenie is all
this gas feed right now this little
white man is sampling microbes and yes
we have microbes at this exchange sites
also the big lights in US and Australia
and bloodstream very firm which
naturally your butt here and going there
so we also analyzing those in different
zones but if you're already an extremum
bias and why do you stop at the world
why or anything big why stop now so that
is why we got cane the next natural step
is to go to extreme floods let's not
even worth street sights high radiation
microgravity let's go to the ISS Space
Station you start a spare non working
together a mouthful of projects and 20
study so I would like to first final it
starts fair status very interesting
because the atmosphere is very similar
to the atmosphere to do Mars under it's
worse analog not very good one but it's
what we have and just to analyze how the
bacteria which are really
radiation assistant well kind of
assistant we use this bacteria wanna
live device which you can see on the
right side instead also have a camera
and we just send it up in customers by
balloon to actually verify sequence
could be or an option see how to start
aspiration looks like also taking up
multiple physical like physical like any
kind of biochemical samples anything was
possible
short time so the data we are kind of
different data available and was
accordingly action process the next step
between are going for a stance where we
can look at higher and one kilometer
waiters as a Space Station and I Space
Station is something a very interesting
habitat and as you maybe know is the SOS
station is a closed system so you can't
just open the window and let fresh air
in and of course all the problems won't
be having closed systems we have it of
course nice a space station as well so
we for example we have removed in the
sleeping spaces where you can see on the
left side you're hanging your sleeping
bag on the wall or ceiling it really
doesn't matter because up and down it's
not really existing nice a space station
and the way of leaving your breathing
out here you are shoot up a cure from
your body on the wall and at some point
it's getting a little bit dirty so what
we did we using hybrid technology not
for long mean sequencing in dunno short
in sequence so they actually sequence
those bugs these bacteria
these microphones and perfectly some can
see how how they actually distinguish
from Earth and that also have been
recently published in uncovered in
several newspapers there will be links
for this and now we also think about
okay we are bringing bacteria definitely
to the space and we actually live in
bacteria there but we also one coming
back we take in bacteria with us so
we're having a new study wafer and our
very talented a PhD student in crystal
Mason left everything qu and been cat
from JPL and NASA working on a project
where they actually trying to monitoring
these turns fair bacteria to earth to
space space earth and when we're
thinking about
that we actually bringing a kind of love
butter back to earth and we have
adaptation these bacterias adapting to
new environments maybe get any more
perishing on my rule interact ah we
maybe should find ways to not bring
every sample back door so we have to
learn to analyze assemble in space one
way to do it is you can see in the upper
right corner is using the first
experience - sequencing in space using
non-important ologies so really just a
little bit bigger than a USB stick
device whirring and along with
sequencing in space and on the right of
a corner you can see our first trial in
para para both flights where we have a
couple of seconds or minimum gravity and
on the lower corner under on the left
side you can see first time the time
local sequencer monocot sequencer minion
is working in space and surprisingly it
works much better in space so we have
significant a better output in space
time on earth and as far as about
currently we have more than 15 nanopore
runs and some of them including library
in space which mainly have been has been
a huge effort from Tsar Wallace and
Everton and Christopher Mason and many
others make it as possible which is a an
opportunity to actually sequencing on
site and the bonus is also if using not
for sequencing you can directly actually
directly measure also methylation States
Dean amplifications and then through
also consequence you know economical RNA
or in English education this is very
exciting it also will reduce the the
transport costs from samples and
maturity l-vector
so of course the question is now we know
that we care in bacteria we can have
samples but should we then also not
start working on protecting other
planets from our bacteria and maybe just
making another this facilities on site
of course so do we actually did we
already contaminated some other planets
most likely yes so to understand and to
minimize contamination based actually
protecting planets like Mars and moon
from a small micro biome and it may
actually can take samples and
understanding their day then there is no
microbiome or mercy movement to
understand which substances and
immunizes were brought up to base we
have to first learn to able to analyze
and sample clean moves at NASA so you
can say here is a colleague of us taking
samples in the green room on the left
side you see the assembling of the new
master one nineteen twenty twenty other
protists all these pictures on the left
side is very exciting so so I we found a
couple of bacteria in the cleanroom back
Musel things really clean and kids are a
huge effort from a NASA chaplain I can
encourage all private space organization
to please to regularly check us as well
so of course so now we know there are
microphones we know there was resistance
bacteria in a space station and we're
talking about if attacked on planets but
what about the effect of us of the
astronauts we are responsible
everybody was sending up there so once
about a Michelson hast and us about a
microgravity on hast any radiation and
our costs so the twins sorry
the 2030 have been a really lucky one
we have to us knows identical twin
brothers ma
Kelly agreed to stay one year on earth
and try to look similar regular in life
and Scott Kelly went to ISS Space
Station for one year one of the longest
space on ice obsession was not about
being and we are allowed to take samples
any kind of samples from the beginning
to the end months before the start then
during the start and ending flight and
the earth and and this is indeed one of
the most comprehensive study of two
individuals basically and one but you
know the data outputs meaning is there a
huge effort a lot of others a lot of
groups to get this collection of data
and encourage everybody's interested in
NASA in space health and in general to
release green this paper it's it's a
milestone it's really actually there's a
lot of samples possible we took bloods
do we took of course is scaling micro
Bianca microbiome and whenever you
thought we also did some methylation
states of fresh samples and you also
very product that were able to take this
samples within 36 hours so yes we take
blood samples put in the capsule and put
it down to earth from the moment where
we got the blood out of the arm until we
can assemble in the lab with 36 hours
yes it's possible
so in the future we of course need to
know a little bit about space health and
microorganism transportation between
facilities and planets and we have to
know which macro is meant and so
I mean which kind of environment and we
need to pull out every data we could get
which have been done previously and we
have the little bit focus again more
organized in the future and that is
awesome by Jean Webb the organization
gene lab is so important to us I'm just
Trish is helping us a lot so space
saturation moon Mars in future so to
make make human survival in the future
possible there's an effect I read a
statistic that we need only 115 humans
on another planet on another station if
to actually guarantee survival of humans
the new species in case of material
because human exploration is something
real and we need to prepare it in the
future and with this I would like to
thank you so many people I actually
can't even put them on one slide but
especially every now second ization will
work with Christopher Mason's an amazing
lab been kept on JPL and of course
gene-lab everybody Gina all these what
makes actually it is possible and in
that booths for opportunity and for this
present a getting this presentation and
it's a little overview and if you have
any questions we would like to encourage
you to ask these questions in the
question box you will answer via email
as soon as possible thank you